déjà sur la grève ça en est où alors ça
en est où déjà ça a commencé le 21
septembre dernier aujourd'hui il y a un
tiers des stations essence dans toute la
France qui ont pas de carburant
aujourd'hui la première ministre
Élisabeth borne a annoncé des
réquisitions donc c'est à dire
concrètement si c'est quoi les
réquisitions réquisitions c'est un arrêt
préfectoral donc il y a un préfet qui va
recevoir le nom d'un certain nombre de
personnes qui travaillent là-bas et donc
ils vont envoyer des gendarmes des
policiers chez les gens en disant bah
voilà demain il faut vous alliez
travailler sur les stocks de carburant
c'est incroyable c'est fou ça parce que
c'est bien d'expliquer ça
parce que j'ai vu plein de gens sur les
réseaux dire ils n'ont pas le droit
alors ils ont absolument le droit en
fait il y a il y a deux deux lois qui le
permettent le premier c'est le code de
la défense donc c'est pas ça qui a été
mentionné ce qu'on n'est pas en guerre
le deuxième c'est le code des
collectivités générales territoriales ça
fait un peu sérieux mais l'idée c'est si
jamais ça atteint l'ordre ou la sécurité
ou la célébrité publique le gouvernement
peut prendre des mesures pour
réquisitionner des personnels pour
assurer la continuité du service alors
vu c'est extrêmement clair ça va être
efficace la réquisition alors c'est
extrêmement possible que ce soit
efficace le problème c'est que c'est ce
que vous disiez effectivement comment
est-ce qu'on force les gens à travailler
c'est ça concrètement il y a un policier
qui va se planter chez vous qui veut
dire voilà là vous allez travailler le
problème c'est que ça ça dépend un peu
de si la personne veut travailler si
elle ne veut pas travailler c'est que
s'expose à des sanctions pénales 6 mois
d'emprisonnement et 10000 € de diamants
mais c'est quoi non mais polo s'il y a
quelqu'un qui veut pas les travailler et
qui se retrouvent en prison les gens
vont ça va alors les gens vont faire un
probablement incroyable le gouvernement
mise sur une stratégie qui est assez
intelligente c'est dire que Total a
publié les salaires des gens qui
travaillent en moyenne chez Total alors
justement et qu'est-ce que c'est quoi
ces salaires parce que c'est vrai que
tout le monde dit on a tous entendu
parler de ces 5000 euros tout le monde
me parle un pote il me dit je veux être
je veux travailler chez Total parce
qu'il gagne 5000 euros c'est quoi cette
histoire alors le
total a publié un comique est presse en
disant la moyenne de ce que gagne nos
salariés c'est environ 100000 euros
c'est une moyenne ce n'est pas le prix
de départ et le mettre en comparaison
avec le salaire moyen des Français qui
évidemment bien moins élevé à peu près
des gros salaires chez Total et des
exactement
quand on fait une moyenne c'est beaucoup
plus élevé l'idée à mon avis de total
c'est de dire ces gens ne sont pas
légitimes à faire la grève parce qu'ils
sont très bien payés d'accord le
gouvernement bien sûr ben va jouer
là-dessus en disant nous on est sur
l'ordre et la sécurité publique si
jamais on le fait pas vous avez des
grèves partout des carburants vous
pouvez pas avoir de carburant pour aller
travailler donc soutenez-nous et nous on
va faire travailler ces gens juste pour
dire c'est vraiment la moyenne 5000
euros donc c'est procuré une fiche de
paye un salarié de chez Total quoi vous
montrer vous allez voir voilà et lui il
est à 1757 euros net par mois donc voilà
donc c'est le salaire d'entrée si je dis
exactement c'est le salaire d'entrée
voilà donc voilà je vous le dis chez
Total et c'est vrai que les gens disent
beaucoup de gens disent on comprend pas
parce qu'on trouve qui sont extrêmement
bien payés qu'est-ce que vous répondez
qu'est-ce que vous comprenez ça ici
autour de la cape Gilles Verdez ben non
moi je j'ai pas compris la stratégie
totale effectivement de balancer des
salaires comme ça parce que ça tient
compte d'un intéressement exceptionnel
en plus donc moi financement j'ai plus
de feuilles de paye comme ça qui me sont
remontés c'est-à-dire que ce sont des
salaires je dirais normaux pour des
Français alors ils sont pas sur payés
ces gens-là qu'est-ce qui réclame les
grévistes parce que alors les grévistes
en fait ils disent que l'année dernière
totale en grand j'ai 14 milliards de
bénéfices et que sur les 6 premiers mois
de cette année ils ont engagé 18
milliards donc ils disent ce sont des
supers profits nous on veut toucher nos
quotas augmenter nos salaires de 10% 7%
de l'inflation et 3% au nom de du
partage des richesses est-ce que c'est
vrai qu'ils ont une prime de 9000 euros
cet été ça c'est beaucoup tourné pour
être tout à fait honnête j'ai pas
vérifié ces informations aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose sur lequel il faut
parce que ça c'est quelque chose avec le
gouvernement sans doute jouer avec ça en
disant nous sommes légitime pour pour
agir Mathieu est-ce qu'on peut
comprendre que Total dit on lui a donné
des primes mais en revanche augmenter
les salaires de 10% quand l'inflation va
revenir à 3%, 3 % et demi dans un
trimestre ben là en revanche eux ils
auront une augmentation de 10% pourra
plus revenir sur les salaires en arrière
et en fait c'est pas tellement qui parce
que tout à l'heure propose quand même un
bonus donc il refuse bonus quand même il
faut le dire bien sûr je pense que au
delà de ça il y a quand même un aspect
politique à tout ça et que le
gouvernement va s'en emparer c'est le
premier test la vraie la vraie première
grève de Elizabeth blonde depuis qu'elle
a été le même Premier ministre c'est un
test avant les retraites si jamais elle
cède mais au-delà de la question des
salaires qui est sans doute légitime
au-delà de la question des salaires si
elle cède c'est à dire que le
gouvernement sera faible et vis-à-vis de
la prochaine réforme de retraite comment
est-ce qu'il va pouvoir mener cette
réforme alors on va on va parler de ce
qui va se passer dans un instant et on
va vous montrer juste des vidéos sur les
réseaux les vidéos qui bossent de ouf
sur la pénurie sont voilà sont ceux qui
sur stock surtout sur qui sur stocke du
carburant remplissant des bidons et
jerrican si certains estiment que c'est
égoïste ont eux d'autres pensent qu'ils
ont raison de stocker pour leur
entreprise leur tondeuse à gazon ou
encore dépanner les proches regardez
j'ai du mal à y croire
[ __ ] sans déconner
c'est pas marrant moi c'est la première
fois je la vois celle-là à chaque
poubelle
les images sont incroyables les images
de stockage oui il paraît que ça va être
interdit de faire ça maintenant
c'est à dire c'est interdit maintenant
de faire ça en fait depuis aujourd'hui
parce que évidemment on a des ceux qui
sont limités alors bien sûr on en
apporte etc mais si jamais tout le monde
stocke des bidons chez soi mais
évidemment les stocks vont diminuer donc
il faut aussi penser et prioriser si
vous avez besoin de la voiture
remplissez votre votre carburant
évidemment mais si jamais vous en avez
pas besoin pourquoi faire des stocks
comme ça en prévision d'une pénurie
c'est la même problématique pendant que
vide alors qu'est-ce qui va se passer
maintenant où est-ce que je pense qu'il
va se passer c'est que le gouvernement
va continuer à mettre la pression
vis-à-vis des syndicats parce qu'il ne
peut pas apparaître comme comme faible
effectivement ils sont pas d'accord
entre eux
qui a été signé mais ils veulent aller
encore plus loin et si j'étais allé
encore plus loin et là la CGT
effectivement n'est pas d'accord avec la
CFDT puisque évidemment la CGT veut
encore plus loin en plus à la déroulé
politique à la nuque et cetera donc sans
position de force d'autant qu'il y a des
élections syndicales bientôt donc il
faut quand même il faut quand même
montrer que l'on est présent moi ce que
je pense qu'il va se passer c'est que
des vidéos comme vous en avez montré on
va continuer à voir que les fils vont
probablement s'allonger parce que les
gens vont peut-être paniquer et que ce
qui si jamais il y a quand même un
message à faire passer c'est si vous
n'avez pas besoin de carburant ne le
remplissez pas une en emmenez pas chez
vous parce que c'est tout le monde qui
paiera alors une des vidéos qui a le
plus Buzzi et il a été elle a été tourné
dans une station-service près d'Évreux
deux voitures de sport ont voulu griller
la longue file d'attente qui s'était
formé regarde
alors là
deux heures d'attente à la station
essence deux mecs qui se pointe en
Porsche ils veulent nous gruger les mecs
qui passent dans l'herbe et tout
tranquille tout va bien le mec il a
ramené la barrière
il est là
[Rires]
franchement il y a pas de respect
c'est incroyable ça c'est fou alors il y
a une autre vidéo que je vais vous
montrer aussi c'est cette vidéo qui est
énormément buée sur Tik Tok c'est ce
gars qui s'est vanté d'avoir dépassé
tout le monde dans la file d'attente
avant d'être réprimé
tout le monde je suis en train de me
klaxonner venez vomir
malheureusement elle est là-bas mec hein
la queue elle est là-bas mais mon
collègue il est devant la voiture elle a
0 km d'autonomie
vous restiez monsieur
ça risque de dégénérer il peut y avoir
des drames demain on aura un gréviste
avec nous qui viendra nous voir dans
l'émission C'est c'est voilà c'est c'est
important aussi d'avoir leur son de
cloche il y a une autre vidéo la vidéo
qui a plus besoin aujourd'hui a été
tourné dans le sud de la France et une
embrouille entre un homme et une femme
qui est allé très très loin regardez
tu fais un mec comme tout le monde c'est
bon c'est bon
et je m'en bats les couilles
[Musique]
c'est bon
vous arrêtez là c'est bon voilà
ça ça va loin
l'exaspération
on dit que même si même si ça se
terminait
il faut que les stocks soient remplis il
faut qu'on puisse continuer en fait
lorsque les ce que ce qui vont être
acquisitionnés sont les gens qui
travaillent sur les stocks de carburant
donc le pétrole qui est déjà raffiné
alors que les gens qui sont en grève
sont les raffinés c'est-à-dire qu'en
gros vous avez un pétrole vous le
modifier et ensuite ça fait le pétrole
que vous pouvez voir dans votre dans
votre voiture donc ça veut dire qu'il
faudrait débloquer d'abord les
raffineries et ensuite que le pétrole
que l'on amène dans la raffinerie arrive
jusqu'au raffinerie puis qu'on aura fini
et ensuite qu'il arrive à la
station-serce puis dans votre voiture
donc on voit bien que c'est un processus
qui est très long ça veut dire quoi dix
jours c'est possible que ça aille
jusqu'à 10 jours ça dépendra de
l'ampleur ça dépendra de l'ampleur et de
la durée en fait de la grève et
peut-être aussi quelque chose souligner
c'est que le week-end il y aura une
manifestation contre la vie chère
soutenue par les nups il est probable
qu'il y ait 1400 là les députés
et il faut aussi on peut imaginer que
bah les gars ont fait si ils se disent
ben il y a peut-être un coup politique à
jouer on est face au gouvernement on va
faire beaucoup de bruit on va faire
monter en embêter français des vidéos
comme ça et ça va se multiplier et
fondamentalement empêcher les gens de
bosser hier de plus qu'il les rend fou
donc si jamais vous les empêchez de
travailler on leur met-on pas d'essence
mais il y a un moment évidemment ça
pourrait aller très loin et moi ce que
je crains c'est que il y a un jour
quelqu'un qui se fait se taper dessus
quoi
il y a énormément de bagarres
donc c'est vrai que ça ça se fasse mal
discuté avec un ami là juste avant de
venir il a fait 40 km pour aller jusque
dans le centre Loir-et-Cher pour aller
remplir sa voiture parce que en région
parisienne 50% des sessions et puis
d'essence exactement donc c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait non mais c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on
fait la la vraie question là aujourd'hui
donc on est j'adore donner de la tournée
le combien là aujourd'hui on est
fin octobre ça sera pas réglé ça me
paraît compliqué en fait je pense que ce
qu'il est possible c'est qu'à un moment
il y a une négociation qui va se faire
de toute façon avec Total énergie en
fait exprès mobile l'autre l'autre
entreprise il y a déjà eu un accord
l'accord est pour rejeté par une partie
des salariés il est possible que Total
énergie négociation qui va être entamée
en fin la question c'est est-ce que les
salariés vont vouloir reprendre le
travail après cet accord et surtout
est-ce que il y a des hommes politiques
qui vont encore avoir un intérêt à faire
monter la sauce pour que tout ça
continue dans leur propre intérêt bien
sûr et c'est ça qui est le pire c'est un
intérêt égoïste Bernard il y a une autre
pénurie qui se prépare aussi si ça
continue comme ça si il y a pas de
d'essence dans les camions c'est que les
magasins ne sont plus alimentés c'est ça
et notamment la solitude
ils peuvent plus livrer les magasins
c'est une catastrophe qu'est-ce qui se
passe pour aller d'autres choses aussi
mais parce que par exemple on a vu que
dans les hauts de France il me semble il
y a des camions scolaires qui n'avaient
pas de pas d'essence donc ils ont pas pu
aller chercher les enfants
puisque les soins pour les diabétiques
et tout les gens qui travaillent etc
c'est déjà extrêmement embêtant mais
imaginons si jamais ça s'applique aux
policiers aux pompiers aux ambulances
c'est quand même extrêmement complexe ça
veut dire qu'on va pas protéger et
soigner les gens qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans ces cas-là c'est on aura des grises
demain je vous le dis Gilles tu peux le
dire on regardait des avec Bernard des
images de policiers poussant leur
voiture parce qu'il y a plus d'essence
il y a des gens les pompiers n'ont pas
l'accès prioritaire et en fait ce qui me
sidère c'est que ça dépend de chaque
département il y a que quelques préfets
qui ont pris des arrêtés c'est que les
prioritaires puissent bosser pourquoi
c'est pas généralisé ça alors encore une
fois ça pourrait être modifié avec les
réquisitions qui vont advenir parce que
c'est un arrêt préfectoral c'est
extrêmement possible dans tous les cas
de toutes les spécialistes que j'ai
interviewé aujourd'hui me disent dans
tous les cas c'est extrêmement possible
que ce soit les gens prioritaires comme
la police comme les pompiers etc qui
pourront aller chercher de l'essence en
priorité avant créer de la polémique
parce que chacun va s'estimer
prioritaire oui mais on peut quand même
imaginer il faut que le service public
et notamment les policiers les pompiers
etc je pense qu'on peut le prendre
honnêtement je pense que les Français
comprendront vraiment que les Français
comprendre
vrai que aussi que Total va le payer le
total ne veut pas trop négocier aussi
parce que la part de marché de fin la
France c'est une petite part de marché
dans le groupe Total donc finalement
pardon mais la France est pas très
important pour ce groupe c'est vrai ça
c'est c'est bien sûr que c'est vrai ah
oui il fait une majeure partie de ses
profits à l'étranger notamment en
Afrique bien sûr il y a beaucoup de
beaucoup de pluie d'extraction et
ensuite on peut exporter du pétrole et
je pense également sur la grève pardon
j'ai oublié de vous dire que quelque
chose tout à l'heure c'est que il y a
déjà les grèves qui crée une pénurie
mais en plus il y a eu deux ristournes
celle de Total et aussi celle du
gouvernement c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait
moins 50 centimes à peu près donc les
gens sont évidemment précipités pour
faire des stocks en prévision de l'hiver
et il y a aussi ces deux phénomènes qui
se sont rencontrés qui ont fait que
finalement on manque de l'anticiper ça
le gouvernement pas du tout je suis pas
certain donc honnêtement je manie le
féministe je suis pas certain vraiment
il y a des stations essence qui en
profitent pour augmenter leurs tarifs
c'est vrai qu'il y a des stations
essence où j'ai vu moi
c'est un truc achète-toi une voiture
directement tu fais le plein des gens
qui passent au bioéthanol ouais pour
pour il y a beaucoup de vidéos sur les
réseaux
où il y a beaucoup de gens qui qui parce
que ça il en reste donc voilà bien sûr
c'est bon et c'est vrai qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui passent au
bioéthanol en tout cas merci à Mory
coûte aussi